okay let's try and win a game or two
okay playing fm omer adams
i'll play london actually
i'll play e4
so indecisive okay let's not play the
wayward queen this time let's play
um something maybe a bit more mainstream
see what uh black is up to
play knight c3 being slightly tricky
here
um i guess we're we're gonna have a
russell emo actually
i'll i'll address alerts after this game
for those that maybe didn't catch what i
said earlier i'm muting alerts during
the games but then i'll
i'll address things between games thank
you dude
oh for the kind words i appreciate that
i know b4 is some idea here
right away maybe
i think i'll play b4 right away
i will admit this is not a line i've
studied specifically before
but it looks interesting
f5 is illogical
i mean the idea for white is to induce
some weaknesses on the queen side
bishop g5 comes to mind
b5 comes to mind
thank you jameson king
i do want to say focus i'll try and read
messages afterwards
um i'd prefer not to continue my losing
streak
okay so we're probably going to trade
and actually the
the weakness that black might end up
with is a d6 pawn
it takes some bishop a3
rookie one might be a
move i probably want to play eventually
also rook b1
we need two other choices here
i think i'll think we need to
more multi-purpose move
so black has a bishop here but currently
the bishops are blocked
by pawns
now probably bishop a3
i might even want to play like rook d1
and d4
and try and open things up
my pieces are moderately well prepared
a lot of the tension like the pawn
tension nolan okay
black finally releases some tension
preventing d4
snubbing my bishop
that's a good move actually
to do
is maybe maneuver the knight to c4
i'm gonna probably put the rook back on
f1 just to
deal with uh a file pressure
yeah if ever if black ever plays f4 i'll
play queen g4
i think can nicely diffuse the attack
oh
it's kind of scary because now that f4
is coming
i could play night 93
the three knight of four queen g1
it's getting interesting i'm a decent
grip on d5
yeah now the point is i have this move
black might end up stacking
at least now there's no knight f4
immediately
it's probably a few ways for black to
sack here
and that's one of them yeah the bishop
is
annoying i take this
and then just oh no my queen
that's so good
it's more like oh no my position
how bad is this i have to try and
survive
looks playable
and queen jigsaw might play g4 actually
that looks really risky though
yeah that's a great move
i have g4
i think i'm i'm much worse here but
there's some maybe practical chances
this move
the rook wants to be on each one
bishop f6 could happen
and i have to play rook h1 anticipating
queen h7
crazy position
i'm basically on castling then the king
might just want to
run to the queen side
also have to watch out for knight g2 man
what is this night doing in my crib
i king can just kind of chill
[Music]
use a knight as a pillow
now is just a time scramble is this it's
a free pawn
another free pawn
oh it's scary still
offer trade
you just want to trade off everything
and then meet
what oh fancy i have to take that
man what is this game this game is
insane
i hadn't i had an easy win
i shouldn't have taken back it should
still be
routine
and take here there we go oh no
is this move don't do it yes
okay
on this game
okay i just want to win the pawn i mean
here king here there's no more checks
but now there's a check
there's no perpetual it better not be
perpetual
bad still complicated though
let's defend the pawn i have a nice
thing of defense
gain some time
i like my chances here but i don't know
if
i know what's gonna happen
now i want to push
checking looks okay
and what is this game
running this and the queen's going to
move though
here we go
it's still not over
now it's over okay
man was that game
a game was ridiculous at least i won the
game
that's what it takes to win a game i
guess
yoink oh for those may be confused about
the 50 move rule
the 50 move rule resets every time a
pawn is pushed
or when something's captured so yeah we
weren't close to 50 move roll that game
oh and
yeah these line this um
it's like uh it's like crypto
all these peaks and valleys also signify
is like
just my struggles in converting a
winning position